hey guys i'm lauren zima and I am here
in defense of the film Fifty Shades of
Grey I read the book it was passable
I saw the movie the movie is amazing the
movie is perfect for if you have nothing
to do but want to have fun play a little
drinking game with me drink every time
you don't get to see a penis you do get
to see boobs and you see a Rita or on
screen that's one time save it for the
end it didn't exactly live up to the
book okay the book involved a lot more
male nudity the movie not so much but
it's a light fun easy film that you can
watch with your friends yes it's
supposed to be dark it didn't turn out
that way the dialogue is not that great
the acting is okay it's okay
sex in the city came out how long ago a
long time ago Fifty Shades is the new
Sex in the City we didn't expect a lot
we didn't get a lot but we needed to see
a movie on Valentine's Day okay yeah
single ready to mingle another reason
watched Fifty Shades of Grey the sequel
and this three cool the third film are
coming out you need to be prepared you
need to be part of the conversation and
continue the water cooler discussion
with your colleagues we have been
closely following the filming of the
next two movies and they look saucy I
mean paparazzi photos we have seen
Dakota Johnson's in a swimsuit at some
points Fifty Shades of Grey might not
have lived up to the sauciness level of
the book but the fact that it didn't
almost made it comical so if you want to
go see great comedy run Fifty Shades of
Grey on a Friday night with your
girlfriends and watch it hey guys make
sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel we will be bringing you tons of
amazing celebrity content and coverage